uh so as you're all aware today marks
the one-year anniversary of Russia's
unprovoked war in Ukraine and to quote
secretary Austin's statement issued
earlier today quote the solemn
anniversary is an opportunity for all
who believe in Freedom rules and
sovereignty to recommit ourselves to
supporting Ukraine's Brave Defenders for
the Long Haul
and recall that the stakes of Russia's
War stretch far beyond Ukraine
alongside our International allies and
partners we remain committed to
supporting the Ukrainian people with the
security assistance they need
to defend their nation and take back
their Sovereign territory and we will
stand with Ukraine for as long as it
takes
and another demonstration of our
enduring commitment earlier today the
Department of Defense announced two
billion dollars in additional security
assistance for Ukraine under the Ukraine
security assistance initiative
the security assistance package
reaffirms the steadfast support of the
United States for Ukraine by committing
additional unmanned aerial systems and
counter uas and electronic warfare
detection equipment as well as critical
ammunition stocks for artillery and
precision fires capabilities that will
bolster Ukraine's ability to repel
Russian aggression for additional
details I'd refer you to our press
release located on defense.gov also
today the secretary spoke by phone with
Ukraine's minister of defense soleski
reznikov
secretary Austin praised Ukraine's
courage and sacrifice that has inspired
and rallied the International Community
to support its efforts to push back
against Russian aggression and he also
provided an update on U.S security
assistance efforts and a readout of that
call is available on the dod website
in addition secretary Austin also spoke
today by phone with Israeli Minister of
Defense Joseph Gallant to discuss topics
of mutual interest and we will have a
readout of that call posted later today
on defense.gov as well
finally today the suicide prevention and
response independent Review Committee
released their independent report
findings and recommendations today
the Department of Defense efforts to
implement a comprehensive and integrated
approach to Suicide prevent prevention
actions will be informed by the work of
the committee which will amplify dod's
current approach in three key priority
areas
these include fostering quality of life
and building healthy climates and
cultures
addressing stigma as a barrier barrier
to help seeking and promoting a culture
of lethal means safety and while we
recognize that suicide has no single
cause even one suicide and that there is
no single preventative action treatment
or cure even one suicide is too many and
we will exhaust every effort to promote
the Wellness Health and morale of our
total Force as secretary Austin has said
previously the Department's most
precious resources are people so we must
spare no effort in working to prevent
suicide within our ranks we must all in
every corner of the department redouble
our commitment to connect with those who
may be hurting and save lives and with
that we'll go to your questions we'll
start with Associated Press leader
quite a bit about warning China against
providing any uh Aid lethal Aid to
Russia
given that has the department seen any
indication so far of any type of aid
particularly lethal Aid going from China
to Russia or any indications that such
is actually happening and then secondly
on the suicide report that you just
mentioned the report recommended a
number of gun safety changes including
waiting periods and raising the the age
for purchasing a weapon
has the department considered any of
those before how difficult will it be to
put any of those into effect considering
some of the stronger gun safety thoughts
particularly among Congress sure thanks
Lita so on your first question in
regards to China and the potential for
providing lethal Aid to Ukraine
we haven't seen them provide lethal Aid
to Ukraine or to excuse me to Russia yet
but we also have noticed that they
haven't taken it off the table and so
you've heard secretary Austin secretary
blinken and others warn China about the
implications of providing lethal
assistance to Russia to include
needlessly needlessly extending this
conflict and the suffering of the
Ukrainian people
I would say ironically China's recent
peace plan proposal includes respecting
the sovereignty of all countries so one
would hope that they mean it and respect
Ukraine's right to exist versus
potentially providing lethal Aid
intended to kill innocent ukrainians and
erase their country so we'll continue to
monitor that closely in regards to the
committee's recommendations we will
review those closely I don't have
anything to announce today in terms of
what steps we may take but again this is
a very important topic to the secretary
and to the the entire Department of
Defense and so we'll we'll certainly be
sure to keep you updated on that front
have any of those particular gun safety
recommendations ever been considered in
the past that you're aware of
just a follow-up on the latest questions
you said you haven't seen them
I'm sorry
sorry uh so you still the other room
um just to follow up on Lita's question
you said that you haven't seen China
provide lethal Aid to Russia yet but
have you seen any chatter any China
having any conversations with Russia
about potentially providing lethal Aid
and then I wanted to ask a second
question about Syria there were four U.S
troops wounded in Syria the other day
can you say anything more about this
mission was it a U.S soft mission was it
a partnered raid and how frequently are
U.S troops involved in combat missions
like these yeah so on your first
question I don't have any specific
intelligence to share I know for example
that secretary blinken and the NSC
strategic communication director have
talked to this and indicated that there
is indications that China is considering
to the possibility of providing lethal
aid but again to this point we have not
seen them do that in regards to Syria
I'd refer you to Central Command for the
specifics on that particular operation
as you are aware they issued a press
release on that the the defeat Isis
Mission continues in Syria and Iraq and
so certainly we have forces that are
committed to that to that operation but
I'd refer you to them for the specific
details can you say whether it's it's
typical
U.S forces to go on these partnered
missions though or was this something
that was out of the ordinary uh not out
of the ordinary the U.S military has
been conducting partnered operations
with the SDF for quite a few years now
so thank you let's go over here I
appreciate your patience on the
microphone we'll go to Dan and they'll
come back to jail
thanks for your time I wanted to drill
down a bit if we can into the usai
package announced today particularly the
the counter uas in it uh looks like
we're we're going to see the switchblade
600 which at least to my knowledge and
if you can clarify that'd be helpful
have not been a part of the package
previously how quickly do you think that
might find its way to a battlefield and
is and is the time it's taken to get it
there a function of it simply not being
available more quickly or or something
else sure
um so so for as you highlight given that
these are usai these are all
capabilities that we will go to Industry
to help produce I don't have a timeline
in terms of the delivery time other than
as has been the case we'll continue to
work very closely with industry to try
to get them there as quickly as we can
in terms of
yeah and I'll just leave it at that more
Loosely is the anticipation that it
would be there in time for the offense
of this spring uh I I think I I don't
think that would be the case again we're
already providing them with a
significant amount of capabilities
coming from PDA along with the
International Community uh to get them
the capabilities they need for the
springtime but again this is a fight
that will continue to be tough and so we
want to ensure not only are we meeting
their immediate needs but we're also
meeting their medium and long-term needs
and so again we're going to rush to get
these capabilities there as quickly as
we can
thanks go to Joe
thanks Matt
um just uh staying on Ukraine Aid there
are a number of categories of Aid where
we didn't get the specificity
um it talked about high Mars ammunition
but High Mars can take
gimlers or attack EMS and I just wanted
to see if you could be specific about
what kind of high Mars ammunition was
part of the package what kind of laser
guided rockets and any specificity you
can give around the counter uas systems
that were included yeah so so on the
specific counter uas systems I'm not
going to get more specifics just for
operation security reasons in the in the
packages you highlight the the laser
guided rocket systems those are Advanced
Precision kill weapon systems so
essentially the ability to convert
unguided Rockets into Precision guided
Munitions which can be operated from
various launchers that we're providing
to the ukrainians so that's about as
specific as I'm going to be able to get
and on the the high Mars ammunition is
that just gimlers or is that something
else uh well I'll have to go back and
take a look
um I'm going to
presuppose that if we're not including
it in there it's probably for operation
security reasons that said I'll take
your question back and we'll see what we
can provide and just uh um in terms of
the the time is there
um because there were a number of uh
drone systems is there a reason why is
there something happening on the
battlefield now that's
um you know requiring that as part of
the usai package I think
it's important to step back and look at
the security assistance that we're
providing holistically right so it's not
episodic one individual battle or one
individual situation at a time it's
essentially a
meshing together a variety of
capabilities to give the ukrainians a
variety of things that they need to be
successful to include air defense
ground-based air defense to include
armor capability to include artillery
the ammunition that they need the
communication command and control
capability that they need so so as the
Department of Defense approaches uh
meeting Ukraine security assistance
needs it's part of a broader framework
of working with them in terms of Meeting
those requirements as quickly as we can
through the means that we have available
to us and it's not just the US again and
I know you know that it's part of an
international tapestry so to speak to
provide those capabilities so so each of
these is going to meet a capability that
the ukrainians have asked for but again
the key word being capability the
platform is going to help meet at
capability need the other aspect of that
is the training piece which we've talked
about talked about before so the
Equipment Plus the training which
includes operations maintenance and
sustainment gives the ukrainians the
capabilities they need not only to
defend but also to go on the offensive
on their timeline in order to change the
equation on the battlefield thanks all
right go here and then we'll go back to
custom thank you Todd I'm following up
on Dan and Joe's questions about the
package on the announcement had quite a
bit and a variety of different drone uas
systems but no quantities so can we get
any specifics on how many of each drone
or the overarching amount that was sent
um no
because I'm sure that's information that
the adversary would absolutely love to
have and we're just not going to talk
about it and then more broadly following
on Joe's question
um thinking about the state of the fight
why are uas being prioritized in this
way what does that really say about the
capability needed and what Ukraine is
asking you for well again I think I
would approach that from two different
uh levels so it's important not to look
at this individually this package
individually as a standalone thing it's
part of a broader array of capabilities
that we're providing which includes uas
encounter us capabilities which oh by
the way again we've been doing for the
duration of this conflict but then
I think it's become apparent to everyone
in the last
five to seven years
you know especially as we we saw groups
like Isis starting to use drones and now
especially in this conflict the
significant impact that drones have and
so
um countering those capabilities for
example the the Iranian drones I think
is critical but then also giving the
ukrainians the capability both from a
strike standpoint but then also from a
intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance standpoint and so that is
that is part of the modern way of
warfare and so it's a capability that
they will be able to employ and have
been employing to great effect and we'll
continue to support them in that regard
let me go to custom and then we'll come
back over here
General thanks so with respect to China
you said you haven't seen Chinese
providing any little aid but it's not on
the table it seems that the United
States is alarmed pretty earlier with
respect to China what is the main
concern with respect to China's little
support how do you think it will affect
the the the battlefield the condition on
the battlefield
yeah well you know without getting into
hypotheticals I mean broadly speaking
what you would be seeing is a country
like China which clearly has advanced
capabilities Munitions Etc which oh by
the way has publicly declared its
neutrality to now take aside and
essentially say we want to be in the
camp that's looking to extinguish
Ukraine as a nation
and so it would again as I mentioned it
would prolong this conflict it would
cause needless suffering among innocent
ukrainians uh and again if if we go back
to the beginning a year ago today Russia
invaded unprovoked the nation of Ukraine
with the idea that they would wipe it
off the map and so the United States and
the International Community have come to
help Ukraine defend itself Ukraine
certainly has a right to defend itself
and we have a right to help them defend
themselves and and this conflict could
end tomorrow if President Putin decided
you know what this isn't working out the
way we thought it would we're going to
stop
so like China providing lethal Aid I
think again uh it would just extend the
suffering of of innocent people
per yesterday's statement we have seen
that United States over one year flight
have provided has provided almost 32
billion dollars of Aid that's that's a
huge amount do you remember if the
United States has provided to another
country that much aid for a conflict
which the United States is not part
party to and and how confident are you
that the United States is going to keep
the pace of providing this Aid to
Ukraine if the war prolongs Beyond next
year and and more years actually yeah
well I think President Biden secretary
Austin uh all senior U.S leaders have
made very clear that we're going to
continue to support Ukraine for as long
as it takes as they defend their nation
and so again
going back a year what we're talking
about here is a
Russian nation that has decided that it
wants to eliminate Ukraine
um
and should they be allowed to succeed
the implications go well beyond
Ukraine it goes into
protecting
the international rules-based order that
is largely prevented
Another World War since World War II
and so the potential implications on the
European security architecture more
broadly the International Security
architecture are significant so again
we're going to continue to support them
for as long as it takes let me go ahead
and go over here and then we'll come
over here yes
tornado Supreme Allied commanders
urged the U.S to do everything they can
for Ukraine to dig deeper I was curious
your reaction to that and what more
could we be doing right now yeah I think
that that message Echoes largely what
secretary Austin said at the Ukraine
defense contact group that we do need to
as an International Community dig deeper
and work harder work faster to ensure
that Ukraine gets the security
assistance that it needs to be
successful on the battlefield does dig
deeper mean sending additional
capabilities equipment what do you take
from that in terms of what we could do
so I think we are again as evidenced by
today's announcement and we're going to
continue to consult closely with Ukraine
and with our International allies and
partners to ensure that that Ukraine has
the assistance that it needs to be
successful
thank you all right we'll go here and
then we'll come back across the room
thank you General General China has been
introduced a plan call for assist fire
in Ukraine including the end of conflict
have you see this plan and what's your
opinion about it and I have another
question sure um well certainly uh we
are aware that that China has introduced
a plan I don't have any specific
comments to provide from a Department of
Defense standpoint our Focus remains on
working with Ukraine and our allies and
partners to to get them the security
assistance that they need I I will say
when it comes to peace talks and
negotiations we've been very clear that
that's a decision for Ukraine to make
and as you've heard us say previously
nothing about Ukraine without Ukraine
thank you
do you think it is necessary to keep
lines of communication with Russia open
even with the relations like we are now
I think it's important absolutely
important to keep the lines of
communication open with Russia also with
China this is something that secretary
Austin has talked about frequently and
that it's an important responsibility of
of all Nations particularly those that
maintain vast military
arsenals to keep those lines of
communication open to reduce the
potential for miscalculation so that's
something that will continue to Endeavor
to do all right we'll go back here we'll
go to Phil and then we'll come right up
here
hold on get the microphone
sorry
fiction line between the United States
and Russia used to coordinate the
president's trip to Ukraine thanks Phil
so so in regards to the president's trip
to Ukraine I'm going to have to refer
you to the White House there uh this was
a presidential trip and so they're
they're really the ones to talk about
that
yes sir
in addition to Iran's request for
fighter jets and combat helicopters from
Russia the White House announced today
that Russia has offered Iran cooperation
on
uh missiles electronics and air defense
in exchange for Iran's support for the
war effort are we talking about
potential purchases here is this
co-production uh and can you get into
any specifics on uh platforms yeah I
really can't Beyond again what you
highlighted that we know that Iran is
pursuing a deeper security cooperation
relationship with Russia for obvious
reasons and throughout this campaign
we've seen sort of that transactional
interaction between Russia as they seek
more Munitions as they seek drone
capability we we know that they've been
interested in ballistic missile
capability for example we know that
they've been looking to advance that
relationship with Iran and again we know
that Iran is looking to advance that
that relationship with Russia which
again says a lot about the the kinds of
the kinds of measures that Russia is
finding itself having to resort to not
able to depend on its own defense
industry uh losing suppliers and
partners as a result of their actions
and so
um and it's also a statement on what
we've said before about Iran being a
destabilizing influence not only in the
Middle East but exporting Terror to
places like Ukraine so again we'll
continue to monitor that closely but I
don't have any additional details to
provide let me go over here and then
we'll come back here
thank you General uh the Ukrainian
president said just the other day that
there's not going to be any dialogue
with Mr Putin and he can't be trusted
while the Russian president says that
they have to accept the new reality is
on the ground and the United States
rhetoric is that Mr Putin could end this
war if you wanted to in a heartbeat
there seems to be a deadlock here right
that so can you see the United States
militarily and financially supporting
Ukraine for the next for the next half a
decade perhaps because it looks like a
deadlock that no one can break at the
moment what's your thought on that yeah
so I'm not going to try to predict the
future I'm going to focus on on the
facts that we have in front of us and
the facts are that Russia invaded its
peaceful Democratic Sovereign neighbor
and that it tried to eliminate Ukraine
as a country and Ukraine is defending
itself and we're going to help Ukraine
defend itself alongside the
International Community and so
ultimately at the end of the day uh
we're not going to dictate to Ukraine
when it should stop fighting
um we wouldn't want someone to tell us
that and we're not going to tell them
when to stop fighting we're going to
focus on supporting them and giving
putting them in the best position
possible so that when they determine
it's time to negotiate or when it's time
to stop fighting they'll have the
strongest possible hand available and so
we'll just leave it at that
so it's not a figure of speech I think
when the United States Administration
says for as long as it takes it's
literally for as long as it takes the
war goes on right
yeah so I guess you know the the
question here is
um what happens next if Russia is
allowed to succeed right it's not going
to stop it at Ukraine uh and it's going
to further embolden other
um authoritarian regimes in terms of
what they can accomplish simply by using
Force to eliminate countries around them
and so
um
I think what we would see is an increase
in the cost of trying to defend
democracy I think what we would see is
an increase in needless suffering and
innocent lives lost and the
extinguishing of freedom and democracy
in countries that that are unable to
defend themselves so so again
as the president has said as secretary
Austin has said we are committed to
supporting Ukraine in their fight
because the implications not only is it
the right thing to do but the
implications extend well beyond Ukraine
in terms of what it means for the
international community and what it
means for democracy and what it means
for Freedom thank you okay take a couple
more yes sir and we'll come over here to
Louie
thank you sir my question is on again
U.S India relations recently two big
events took place in India in Delhi
Republic of India and also in Bengaluru
air show but at both events India
displayed for the first time everything
all the weapons Made in India but
amazingly at the magaluri air show U.S
amazed thousands of people on the ground
and millions around the globe are
displaying
F 22 and F35 my question is that all
these made Indian weapons how much this
department played role making in India
Made in India weapons and second
recently a big Boeing
and also India orders big over 200 plain
civilians of course but is there any in
the displayed military to military any
weapons coming to India from the U.S
um so appreciate the question I'm gonna
have to get back to you on that I'm not
I'm not tracking that specifically as
you as you know the U.S in India enjoy a
good partnership we look forward to
continuing to develop and Foster our
relationship with the Indian military
but I'll have to come back to you on
that and just quickly secretary blinken
will be in India as secretary Austin
going anytime soon or if Indian defense
minister will be in Washington thanks
sir thank you I don't I don't have any
uh travel right now to announce but
we'll certainly keep you updated if
that's the case all right I've got time
for a couple more go to Louis
um in your response to latest question
when she asked about the lethal age from
possibilities from China you said that
we haven't seen any lethal Aid go from
China to Russia but you also said you'll
notice that they've not taken it off the
table
what do you mean by that I mean they
haven't actually confirmed that so when
you're saying that they haven't taken it
off the table
what are you looking for and what are
you inferring yeah so again I think this
goes back to the comments that you've
seen coming out of state department and
the NSC in terms of we have indications
that they're contemplating
providing lethal Aid again I don't have
any intelligence specific intelligence
to the details to get into and so that's
why you've seen U.S leaders
communicate again to China the potential
implications of providing lethal Aid to
Russia
but you've not seen a response from them
that would indicate that it is off the
table
we've not seen anything at this point to
indicate that it's off the table
thank you um last night the department
issued a press release about the U.S
Republic of Korea exercise the tabletop
exercise about the possibility of a of
North Korea using a nuclear device is
that typical for the Department to
disclose the scenarios of its tabletop
exercises and in this case was that done
intentionally for the deterrence value
which specific part are you talking
about well the one where you acknowledge
that the scenario that the tabletop
exercise looked at was specifically
dprk's potential use of a nuclear device
and how both the Rock and the U.S as
part of their Ironclad I see
um Louie I don't know the answer to that
let me let me get the facts and I'll
come back to you on that thanks all
right get time for one more we'll go to
custom
the general also Russia recently
announced that they are going they
suspend the participation in the new
start and
agreement do you have any concern with
respect to that and is there any posture
changes in a Russian nuclear uh Force
posture sure
um so
we think that it's unfortunate that
they've decided to suspend their
participation in the new start treaty
it's irresponsible given the potential
implications here of of what we're
talking about but in regards to Russian
strategic forces posture we have not
seen any indication that they have
changed nor have we changed our posture
thank you